[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
in allen guten Abend am anderen Ende der
Welt war es eine kurze Nacht der
US-Präsident und der aus Frankreich der
deutsche Bundeskanzler sie alle wurden
von ihren Beratern aus dem Schlaf
geklingelt
Raketeneinschlag in Polen das ist die
Nachricht mit der man einen Staatsmann
stören darf und muss der G20-Gipfel
hatte gerade Russlands Krieg so klar und
einmütig verurteilt wie kein derartiges
Gremium zuvor da steht plötzlich die
Möglichkeit im Raum dass die NATO also
auch Deutschland ganz direkt in diesen
Krieg hineingezogen wird
mittlerweile sagen sie in Brüssel und
Warschau es war kein russischer Angriff
sondern wohl eine ukrainische
abwehrrakete es war auf jeden Fall eine
schwierige Nacht und ein Tag an dem
Europa endgültig klar werden muss was
ist für uns alle bedeutet dass auf
diesem Kontinent ein Krieg tobt auch
darüber spreche ich gleich mit dem
Bundeskanzler erst eine Gellinek aus
Bali
der Raketeneinschlag in Polen lässt auch
auf der 11.000 km entfernten Tropeninsel
Bali die Gipfel Agenda durcheinander
geraten aber diesen einen Termin wollen
die Staats- und Regierungschefs und
Chefinnen dann doch noch absolvieren in
weißen Poloshirts Pflanzen sie mehr oder
weniger geschickt man großen Bäume in
einem Sumpfgebiet das war's dann aber
auch schon zum Thema Klimaschutz die
Reaktion auf den raketenabsturz
überlagert alles schon am frühen Morgen
hatte der amerikanische Präsident die
westlichen Partner zur Krisensitzung
zusammengetrommelt Kanada Japan und die
Anwesenden europäischen Regierungschefs
brieten darüber wie der Westen auf
diesen Vorfall reagieren soll
während sich die Welt hier auf dem
G20-Gipfel versammelt hat um die Lage zu
entspannen eskaliert Russland weiter in
der Ukraine
während wir uns treffen werden unzählige
Raketenangriffe geflogen das
amerikanische Militär aber weiß längst
mehr mit Computern gespickte
überwachungsflugzeuge und unbemannte
Drohnen fliegen täglich
Aufklärungsmissionen über der Ukraine
und hören die komplette Kommunikation ab
Ihre Daten lassen schnell den Schluss zu
dass es sich um eine ukrainische
abwehrrakete gehandelt haben könnte noch
gestern hatten sich die G20
Gipfel-Teilnehmer dafür gefeiert dass
sie es gegen alle Wahrscheinlichkeit
geschafft hatten eine Abschlusserklärung
hinzubekommen die Russlands Krieg scharf
verurteilt heute aber im Licht der
ukrainischen Rakete auf Polen
verschwimmt diese Linie wieder
der türkische Präsident und Nato-Partner
Erdogan zum Beispiel fühlt sich
bestätigt am Krisentreffen mit den
westlichen Verbündeten nimmt er lieber
gar nicht teil er will weiterhin als
Vermittler zwischen Russland und der
Ukraine fungieren und umschmeichelt
Putin
ich respektiere die Erklärung der
Moskauer Regierung das Russland nicht
involviert ist diese Erklärung ist sehr
wichtig für uns
der neue britische Premierminister
hingegen gehört zu den antiputin
Hardlinern die von den Ukrainern
abgeschossene abwehrrakete sei
schließlich nur eine Folge der
russischen Aggression
russland hat über 80 Raketen auf
ukrainische Zivilisten und deren
Infrastruktur herabregnen lassen das ist
ein Fakt es ist barbarisch es ist falsch
und das darf man bei dieser Diskussion
nicht aus dem Blick verlieren
als das Treffen auf Bali zu Ende geht
ist Russland stärker isoliert als je
zuvor doch die Allianz gegen Putin ist
wirklich und Russlands Raketen bislang
stärker als jede Abschlusserklärung
eines g20-clubs
so und vor seinem langen Rückflug zurück
nach Deutschland einmal rund um die Welt
spreche ich jetzt auf Bali mit dem
Bundeskanzler Herr Bundeskanzler guten
Tag nach Bayern
guten Tag ich würde gerne beginnen mit
den
raketeneinschlägen in Polen ändert das
für sie jetzt alles oder war für sie
klar dass so etwas früher oder später
passieren müsste quasi
zunächst mal bin ich traurig über die
Opfer dieser Raketen
Anschläge die in Polen stattgefunden
haben auch über die Zerstörung ich habe
auch nicht sofort in Verbindung gesetzt
mit dem polnischen Präsidenten und eben
das Mitgefühl der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
Deutschlands und mein persönliches
Mitgefühl übermittelt klar ist dass wir
jetzt sehr vorsichtig sein müssen es
dürfen keine Gerichte über die Frage
entstehen besten Rakete das nun war die
da eingeschlagen ist das muss sorgfältig
untersucht werden und das haben wir
veranlasst auch der amerikanische
Präsident hat der polnischen Regierung
angeboten bei der Untersuchung zu helfen
und wir wissen natürlich gleichzeitig
dass das alles egal von wem die Rakete
abgeschossen wurde und welches Ziel sie
eigentlich hatte nicht stattfinden würde
wenn es nicht den fruchtbaren Krieg
Russland gegen die Ukraine gäbe und auch
die furchtbare Kriegsführer
holen will jetzt dass der nato-artikel 4
greift das ist also etwas schwächer als
der Beistandspakt in Artikel 5 was würde
daraus dann ganz konkret Folgen für die
NATO
wir haben schon hier in Bali und schnell
zusammengesetzt das sind ja viele
Regierungschefs und Regierungschefin der
NATO-Staaten hier versammelt haben
einige Freunde dazu genommen und beraten
was wir tun wollen ein Ergebnis habe ich
bereits mitgeteilt und wir werden das
weiter beobachten es werden auch die
Botschafter der NATO miteinander
sprechen natürlich muss die Situation
sorgfältig bewertet werden gut ist dass
sich den sicheren Eindruck gewonnen habe
dass alle besonnen sind
und auch besonnen bleiben sollten ist
dass ihr Appell heute
das ist notwendig angesichts eines
solchen Krieges es findet Krieg in
Europa statt direkt vor unserer Haustür
und deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir
alles dafür tun dass einerseits die
Ukraine unterstützt wird auch mit Waffen
und solange wie das notwendig ist dass
wir aber gleichzeitig eine Eskalation zu
einem Krieg zwischen der Nato und
Russland verhindern und das machen wir
der Bundeskanzler sie sind am Ende jetzt
eines G20-Gipfels auf Bali in der
Abschlusserklärung steht die meisten
Staaten verurteilen den russischen Krieg
aufs schärfste dennoch haben wir gestern
gerade wieder heftigst gesehen
bombardiert Russland weiter welchen Wert
hat so eine Abschlusserklärung
zunächst mal ist ziemlich klar dass
Russland alleine da steht und nur wenige
Verbündete hat das ist geht weit über
die Zahl der Länder hinaus die bei der
Generalversammlung verändertation gegen
den russischen Krieg gestimmt haben auch
diejenigen die sich enthalten haben sind
nicht einverstanden deshalb waren auch
so klare Worte hier bei den Gipfel
möglich auch klare Worte im Hinblick auf
die Tat aber auf die auf die Nutzung von
Atomwaffen ist es klar gesagt wenn diese
Waffen dürfen in dem Krieg nicht
eingesetzt werden und es ist ein großer
Erfolg dass hier drin ist wenn ich
wieder kurz unterbrechen darf diese
Waffen dieser Atomwaffen dürfen nicht
eingesetzt werden sagen alle Staaten da
damit darf auch nicht gedroht werden mit
dem Einsatz von Atomwaffen das hat
interessanterweise auch Russland
unterschrieben derselbe Staat der die
ganze Zeit mit dem Einsatz von
Atomwaffen droht
das verstehe ich nicht
nein in Wahrheit ist es doch so dass im
Hinblick auf die von Ihnen jetzt
berichtete Sprache Russlands in der
Vergangenheit die Bedeutung dieser
gipfelerklärung nur noch höher gewertet
werden kann das ist gelungen und ich bin
sehr froh darüber dass ich einen Teil
der Vorbereitung dafür auch mit möglich
machen konnte zum Beispiel durch meinen
Besuch in China und die klaren Worte die
auch der chinesische Präsident in diese
Frage mit mir gemeinsam gefunden hat aus
meiner Sicht ist das jetzt ein Weg der
nun mal verbaut ist und das ist wichtig
dass das hier passiert ist und
gleichzeitig ist es so dass wir jetzt
Russland auffordern müssen nicht sinnlos
diesen Krieg weiter zu führen sondern
ein Weg rauszusuchen zum Beispiel durch
den Rückzug von Truppen und die
Bereitschaft zu fairen Gesprächen die
keinen Diktat Frieden gegen die Ukraine
zum Ziel haben wie das doch schon so
lange leider auf Russland Seite der Fall
war interess sie gerade gesagt haben der
Weg ist jetzt verbaut das heißt sie
erwarten ganz konkret dass es von
Russland keinerlei Drohungen in
irgendwelcher Art mit Atomwaffen mit
Atomwaffeneinsatz mehr geben wird
es gibt viele Atomwaffen auf der Welt
und solange die existieren wird das
immer eine Gefahr bleiben was wir heute
erreicht haben ist ja
ein
Block den wir eingeschlagen haben etwas
das wirklich jetzt erstmal in dieser
Situation ein sehr beeindruckendes
Statement ist ja aber was absolut
deswegen stehen
das heißt sehr konkret wenn alle
gemeinsam sagen dass der Einsatz von
atomkraftwaffen in diesem Krieg
ausgeschlossen ist dann muss man davon
ausgehen dass das jetzt auch von allen
so beachtet wird
jetzt war der russische Außenminister
bei dem Treffen ja mit im Raum die haben
wir uns das vorzustellen wie sind sie
und die anderen mit Sergej laborova
umgegangen
er hat seinen Beitrag gehalten
und dann
hat jemand geantwortet war einiges
schweigen oder wie hat man sich das
andere
vorher und hinterher haben viele Länder
das drückt sich ja auch in der
gipfelerklärung dann aus da geht 20
Erklärung gesagt dass sie diesen Krieg
verurteilen und dass sie Russland
auffordern den Krieg zu beenden Sie
sagen der russische Außenminister hat
seinen Beitrag gehalten der Präsident
der Ukraine silenski war auch
zugeschaltet beim Gipfel da war Lauf mit
im Raum
ist das dann so ich versuche mir das
gerade vorzustellen dass sie alle rüber
gucken zu laufen ihn quasi dabei
angucken oder gucken sie extra Weg
schweigen sie wie haben sie versucht die
ihre Haltung auch gegenüber dem
russischen Außenminister klar zu machen
ich habe meine Haltung mit Worten klar
gemacht als ich die Gelegenheit hatte zu
sprechen und zwar bei allen
Gelegenheiten die sich geboten haben und
ich war nicht der einzige das ist das
was wir auf einem solchen Gipfel machen
können und dann natürlich rechtzeitig
politische Weichen zu stellen die solch
eine gipfelerklärung dann auch
ermöglichen daran will ich noch mal
ändern die Welt hat sich verändert und
sie wird sich weiter ändern viele Länder
im globalen Süden in Asien in Afrika und
im Südamerikas werden künftig mitreden
über die Entwicklung der Welt darunter
auch viele Demokratien die ich ganz
bewusst deswegen zum Beispiel nach
Deutschland zu dem G7 Gipfel nach Elba
eingeladen hatte Indonesien Indien
Südafrika Senegal und Argentinien die
auch teilweise für ihre Kontinente
sprechen und ganz klar ist dass das ein
Beitrag dazu leistet dass hier eine
solche Verständigung möglich ist wir
werden auf Augenhöhe mit diesen Ländern
die Zukunft der Welt miteinander
gestalten müssen und vielleicht ist der
heutige Gipfel und das was wir im Laufe
des Jahres unternommen haben um mit all
diesen Ländern zu sprechen ein
Vorzeichen dafür dass das gelingen kann
sie haben gesagt es wäre gut gewesen
wenn auch der russische Präsident
gekommen wäre nach Bali was wäre dann
anders gelaufen
da hätte selber zuhören müssen wie so
viele Länder klar machen dass sie mit
seinem Vorgehen und mit seinem Krieg
nicht einverstanden sind wahrscheinlich
ist er deshalb weggeblieben der
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz am Ende eines
wichtigen Gipfeltreffens der G20 auf
Bali guten Rückflug der Bundeskanzler
und danke fürs Gespräch
schönen Dank
das Gespräch haben wir heute Vormittag
aufgezeichnet unmittelbar vor dem sehr
langen Rückflug des Kanzlers
es gibt keine Anzeichen für einen
vorsätzlichen Angriff auf Polen das ist
der Satz des Tages er kommt von der
polnischen Regierung er kommt von der
NATO und bei jedem der Ihnen sagt kann
man die Erleichterung dabei förmlich
mithören russland hat kein NATO-Mitglied
angegriffen auch nicht aus Versehen wir
sind noch mal drumherum gekommen um eine
Situation deren Folgen wir uns nicht
ausmalen möchten aus Polen mehr von
Natalie Steger
ein Dorf ist verletzt das polnische
hübsche wortoff nahe der Grenze zur
Ukraine gestern kam der Krieg noch näher
Raketeneinschlag zwei tote Einwohner man
kennt sich hier in der Schule kein
Unterricht heute die Menschen in Sorge
dieses Geräusch war ein riesiger Schock
riesige Angst und unsere Rolle ist jetzt
den Kindern zu erklären was passiert ist
und wie man sich perspektivisch
verhalten soll
gestern also das was Polen seit Monaten
fürchtet Raketeneinschlag im eigenen
Land die Untersuchungen vor Ort unter
Hochdruck eine Krisensitzung nach der
nächsten Polen behielt einen kühlen Kopf
keine vorschnellen Schuldzuweisungen
oder gar selber Rasseln nun die
offizielle Einschätzung
wir haben absolut keinen Hinweis oder
Indizien die uns erlauben zu sagen dass
es eine Attacke auf Polen war
höchstwahrscheinlich war es ein
unglücklicher Unfall
Polen geht davon aus dass es sich um
eine ukrainische Flugabwehrrakete
handelt sowjetischer Bauart Teil der
ukrainischen Luftabwehr Warschau sieht
explizit Moskau dafür verantwortlich
dass es zu dem Querschläger kommen
konnte
der gestrige Tag ist ein Tag der
massenraketenattacke auf das ganze
Gebiet der Ukraine um diesen massiven
Raketenangriff abzuwehren haben die
ukrainischen Kräfte ihre Raketen
gefeuert konterraketen um die russischen
Raketen abzuschießen
der ukrainische Präsident selenski zeigt
sich in einer Videobotschaft zum
G20-Gipfel irritiert über die
Erkenntnisse die Ukraine verlangt
sofortigen Zugang zum Explosionsort in
Polen leider gab es Opfer und nicht nur
in der Ukraine russische Raketen haben
das Nachbarland Polen getroffen es
sollte eine schnelle Antwort geben
Polen einer der entschiedensten
Unterstützer der Ukraine beschwört den
Zusammenhalt
Ministerpräsident moabiewski warnt davor
sich von Moskau in dieser Sache
auseinander dividieren zu lassen
im polnischen grenzortschebau ist das
ohnehin angeschlagene Sicherheitsgefühl
seit gestern nicht besser geworden aus
Warschau hören Sie keine bekannte
direkte neue Gefahr doch hier heißt es
es hätte auch mich treffen können
hektische Telefonate Krisensitzungen und
dann die Gewissheit der Bündnisfall ist
der NATO noch mal erspart geblieben
Florian neuhahn guten Abend wir beide
haben gestern miteinander gesprochen da
war vieles weit weniger klar wie kann
man denn heute das Signal zusammenfassen
dass die NATO an ihre Mitglieder aber
eben auch an Russland schicken will
es ist zuallererst ein Signal der
Entspannung der Deeskalation in die
eigenen Reihen aber eben auch nach
Moskau als wir gestern hier Sprachen da
war ja noch die Rede von einer sehr
vorsichtigen Reaktion der NATO und man
sprach vorsichtig nur von einer
Explosion wollte kein Wort verlieren
über mögliche Urheber oder egal über
Konsequenzen und das scheint nach den
heutigen Erkenntnissen ja doch die
richtige Haltung gewesen zu sein weil
sich eben vieles anders darstellt als
wir hier zuerst befürchtet haben wo man
ja schon hatte von einem Dritten
Weltkrieg zwischen den beiden großen
Blöcken NATO und Russland und dann ist
es auch sicherlich ein Signal an Moskau
gewesen wie auch gerade im Gespräch von
Bundeskanzler Scholz gehört ja man weiß
die Rakete stammte wohl aus der Ukraine
aber der Westen sieht die Verantwortung
für diesen fehlgeleiteten Schuss
eindeutig nicht in der Ukraine sondern
beim Krümel und was sagt die NATO zu dem
ukrainischen Präsidentin der ja auch
heute der Natur widersprochen hat und
dabei bleiben will es sei eine Rakete
der Russen gewesen
ja das war wirklich bemerkenswert zu
beobachten heute auch bei der
Pressekonferenz des
nato-generalsekretärs Jens ist
Stoltenberg hier in Brüssel als er nach
diesen massiven Widersprüchen aus Kiew
gefragt worden ist da hat der faktisch
kurz darauf geantwortet aber dann jeden
Hauch einer Kritik an der ukrainischen
Regierung tunlichst vermieden und das
zog sich auch durch Hintergrundgespräche
an diesem Tag ich denke es ist nicht das
erste Mal dass selenski hier etwas
überzieht aber erstens ist man im Westen
geneigt dem ukrainischen Präsidenten und
seiner Regierung doch viel mehr zu
verzeihen einfach weil das Land sich
gerade in einem brutalen Angriffskrieg
befindet und verteidigt und zweitens
weil man eben auf jeden Fall sich nicht
spalten lassen will vor der
Weltöffentlichkeit und erst recht nicht
vor den Augen moske aus jetzt ist ja ein
Fakt klar es gibt unzählige
Raketenangriffe durch Russland auf die
Ukraine auch nahe an polnischen Gebiet
es ist grenzt quasi an ein Wunder sagen
Beobachter das nicht früher was passiert
ist was lernen wir alle denn aus dieser
Situation jetzt für die Zukunft
ich glaube alle die sich an dieses
Grundrauschen dieses langen Kriegs neun
Monate jetzt fast längst gewöhnt haben
die sind heute gestern wohl noch einmal
aufgewacht der Vorfall hat uns allen
dramatisch verdeutlicht wie nah dieser
Krieg mittlerweile an die Nase heran
gerückt ist um die Schnelle auch auf ein
nato-mitgliedsland Überschwappen könnte
und wir müssen davon ausgehen dass ich
solche Vorfälle wiederholen können zumal
auch hier in Brüssel die meisten davon
ausgehen dass sich dieser Krieg noch
Monate hinziehen dürfte und in so einer
Situation dürfte es besonders wichtig
sein so besonnen zu reagieren wie
gestern Abend eben nicht im ersten
Impuls nachzugeben das gilt für
Beobachter aber erst recht für die
Menschen in der politischen
Verantwortung da hilft es vielleicht
doch noch mal zuerst eine Nacht darüber
zu schlafen wichtige und interessante
Analyse wie immer Florian herzlichen
Dank dafür
und weitere Nachrichten von heute hast
du jetzt im Blick Hannah
heute müssen sich corona-infizierte in
Bayern und Baden-Württemberg nicht mehr
isolieren und auch in Schleswig-Holstein
fällt die isolationspflicht weg und zwar
ab morgen liegt ein positiver Test vor
muss außerhalb der eigenen Wohnung 5
Tage lang eine medizinische oder eine
ffp2-maske getragen werden draußen ist
das nicht nötig sofern ein
Mindestabstand von anderthalb Metern
eingehalten wird für Beschäftigte und
Besucher von Pflegeheimen gelten
strengere Regeln
ein iranisches Gericht hat drei weitere
regierungskritische Demonstranten zum
Tode verurteilt das berichtet die
iranische Nachrichtenagentur Fars
bereits in den letzten Tagen hatte die
iranische Justiz gegen zwei Mitglieder
der Protestbewegung Todesstrafen
verhängt auch heute gingen wieder
Menschen auf die Straße in der Nacht
demonstrierten tausende im ganzen Land
gegen die iranische Führung mindestens
zwei Teilnehmer sollen dabei getötet
worden sein
bundesaußenministerin baerbock hat auf
der Welt Klimakonferenz in Ägypten
höhere einspazierer bei Treibhausgasen
gefordert vor allem für die nächsten
zehn Jahre es lohne sich um jedes zehnte
Grad weniger Erderwärmung zu kämpfen die
Verhandlungen über klimaentschädigungen
für ärmere Staaten bezeichnete bärbock
als schwierig wichtig sei es jedoch das
Thema anzufassen erklärte sie
bundesinnenministerin ferser hat
angekündigt mit aller Härte gegen die
organisierte Kriminalität in Deutschland
vorzugehen bei der Herbsttagung des
Bundeskriminalamts stellte Faeser dazu
ein neue Strategiepapier vor so sollen
Bund und Länder bei der Bekämpfung von
klaren Kriminalität künftig enger
zusammenarbeiten und es soll mehr Geld
und Personal geben im Kampf gegen
Geldwäsche setzt fazer auf die
Einführung einer bargeldobergrenze von
10.000 Euro
nach dem Brand in einer
Flüchtlingsunterkunft in
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern vor vier Wochen
ist ein Tatverdächtiger Feuerwehrmann
festgenommen worden laut
Staatsanwaltschaft gibt es bisher keine
Hinweise für einen politischen
Hintergrund der Tat sondern dafür dass
sie Teil einer Brandserie war der
Tatverdächtige beschreitet die Vorwürfe
die Flüchtlingsunterkunft in groß
strömkendorf war am 20 Oktober fast
vollständig abgebrannt die 14
ukrainischen Bewohner und ihre drei
Betreuer blieben unverletzt
das hat es in dieser Form in Deutschland
noch nie gegeben und es hat nichts mit
dem in der Bundeshauptstadt gerne
bemühten Charme des organisierten Chaos
zu tun es ist eine Klatsche für
Verwaltung und Politik und es
erschüttert ganz grundsätzliche
Gewissheiten der Gesetzgeber in Berlin
das Landesparlament so wie es im Moment
aussieht ist nicht legitimiert weil die
Wahl aus der es hervorgegangen ist
dermaßen dilettantisch vorbereitet und
mangelhaft durchgeführt wurde dass sie
jetzt ungültig ist das haben die
Berlinerinnen und Berliner seit heute
schriftlich von ihrem
Verfassungsgerichtshof die Wahl muss
komplett wiederholt werden und zwar
schnell und damit könnte Berlins Politik
erheblich durcheinandergewirbelt werden
wie Markus groß und Kassen während
berichten
er soll das nächste Chaos verhindern
Stefan bröchler ist Berlins neuer
Landeswahlleiter seine Vorgängerin
musste wegen der Pannen zurücktreten 90
Tage hat der Verwaltungsfachmann nun
Zeit um die Wahlwiederholung zu
organisieren er nennt das eine
Herkulesaufgabe ein wichtiger Punkt um
dich wieder ins Chaos zu laufen das
erstens eine gute Schulung der
wahlhelfen da sind wir dabei ein zweiter
Punkt ist zu versuchen dass es eben
nicht wieder zu diesen
schlangenbildungen kam kommt wir sorgen
dafür dass ausreichend Stimmzettel zur
Verfügung stehen und werden hier auch
quasi haben wir eine kleine Einheit zur
Verfügung gestellt dass wenn es zu
Engpässen kommt wir quasi von hier aus
auch reagieren können der 26 September
2021 ein Wahltag mit unzumutbaren
Wartezeiten zu wenigen Kabinen falschen
fehlenden oder kopierten Wahlzetteln
vielfachen Stimmabgaben auch nach 18 Uhr
ein systemisches
organisationsversagen nennt das der
Berliner Verfassungsgerichtshof und
urteilte mit sieben zu zwei Stimmen
die mandatsrelevanten Wahlfehler im
vorliegenden Fall so häufig und
schwerwiegend aufgetreten sind dass nur
eine komplette Wiederholung der Wahlen
in ganz Berlin einen verfassungsmäßigen
Zustand herstellen können nach dem
Urteil schaltet Berlin in den
Wahlkampfmodus das wahlchaos beschämend
für die Stadt darin sind sich
Regierungen und Opposition ausnahmsweise
mal einig ich glaube wenn dieses Urteil
eins deutlich gemacht hat so wie Berlin
regiert wird so wie Berlin strukturiert
ist so darf es nicht bleiben
selbstverständlich müssen wir alles
dafür tun dass so etwas nie wieder
vorkommt bei der nächsten
Wahlwiederholung darf nicht schiefgehen
aber es bedeutet auch wir können jetzt
nicht einfach zu Tagesordnung übergehen
ein grüner seidenhieb auf ihn Andreas
Geisel vom Koalitionspartner SPD damals
innen heute Bausenator er trägt die
politische Verantwortung für die
chaoswahl nach der seine Partei genossen
90er Giffey Regierungschefin wurde ich
bin selbst in
Verantwortung heute war aber nicht in
der Verantwortung als diese Wahl erfolgt
ist wir bringen Berlin gut durch die
Krise wir kümmern uns um die Aufgaben
die jetzt anstehen unklar ob die SPD das
Rote Rathaus verteidigen kann Umfragen
sehen momentan grüne und cdu-form
Berlins Landeswahlleiter hat schon
tonnenweise Papier für die Stimmzettel
bestellt und die Suche nach fast 40.000
Helfern gestartet Wahlwiederholung am 12
Februar
die damalige Landeswahlleiterin musste
gehen politische Verantwortung für das
Debakel hat bislang niemand übernommen
denken wir jetzt mal kurz zurück an die
Zeit vor der Wahl 2016 in den USA als
ein immobilienmogul und reality Showstar
plötzlich Präsident werden wollte einer
der Trump Eiswasser und Trump success
Parfum vermarktet hatte und sich durch
Debatten und Talkshows polterte und als
Legionen von politexperten sicher waren
der hat keine Chance
nun er ist wieder da und er will es noch
mal wissen schließlich habe er bereits
zwei Mal das Weiße Haus gewonnen lügt er
seinen Anhängern vor aber auch für einen
Donald Trump haben sich die Zeiten
geändert zeigt Jutta Sonne
wir sind in slains will West Virginia
die kleine Gemeinde ist eine
republikanische Hochburg die 283
Einwohner sind fast alle sehr christlich
gegen Abtreibung für Recht und Ordnung
und in der Vergangenheit auch
mehrheitlich für Donald Trump auch Alex
der eine große Rinderfarm führt war
bisher eingefleischter Trump Anhänger
doch das der nun wieder Präsident werden
will findet Service nicht wirklich gut
zusammen
er stand für etwas er war pro Amerika
das waren viele Leute deswegen haben sie
noch unterstützt ich würde sagen dass er
heute nicht mehr eine so starke Kraft
ist wie noch vor ein paar Jahren
weil
er sich innerhalb der Partei zerstritten
hat da laufen persönliche Animositäten
ich glaube er kommt mit seinem inneren
Kreis nicht mehr so gut zurecht wie
früher
dass ihm immer mehr der Rückhalt
wegbröckelt auch an der Basis das
scheint Donald Trump zu wissen daher
trat er gestern Abend den Florida
weniger aggressiv weniger Poltern vor
seiner Anhänger in ungewohnt ruhigem Ton
verkündete er seine
Präsidentschaftskandidatur für 2024
demontierte die beiden Regierung und
stilisierte sich selbst wieder als
Heilsbringer
der Untergang Amerikas wird uns von
beiden und den radikalen Linken
Geisteskranken aufgezwungen ich glaube
dass amerikanische Volk wird
mehrheitlich diese linke Politik des
Ruins ablehnen und sie werden unsere
Agenda der nationalen Größe und des Roms
für Amerika unterstützen
warum wirft Donald Trump ausgerechnet
jetzt seinen Hut fürs Weiße Haus in den
Ring die einen sagen um sich einen
Vorsprung gegenüber anderen
republikanischen Kandidaten zu sichern
andere meinen Trump wie sich so vor
diversen Strafverfolgungen schützen
dabei wächst täglich die Zahl
prominenter Republikaner die sich vom
Ex-Präsidenten distanzieren
die Zwischenwahlen letzte Woche sind ein
Beispiel dafür dass Trump unfähig ist
Wahlen zu gewinnen er hat er den
Demokraten geholfen als den
Republikanern ich finde wenn man
konservativ regieren will dann muss man
auch Wahlen gewinnen Donald Trump kann
keine Wahlen gewinnen
Pharma Alex saueres wird in zwei Jahren
auf jeden Fall wieder republikanisch
wählen sagte aber auf keinen Fall wieder
Donald Trump es müsse eine neue Garde in
Amerika ans Ruder so saures konservative
Politiker die das Land weniger aufhetzen
und Spalten
offen ist ob Joe Biden der am Sonntag 80
wird noch mal antreten wird
möglicherweise jetzt erst recht sicher
ist nichts und was passiert wenn man
Donald Trump unterschätzt haben die
republikanische Partei die USA und die
Welt ja bereits erlebt
bei uns in der Sendung jetzt noch mal
Johanna ja die Aussichten für die
deutsche Wirtschaft waren in den
vergangenen Monaten ja vor allem eins
nämlich ziemlich düster doch der
angekündigte Konjunktureinbruch könnte
weniger dramatisch ausfallen als
prognostiziert zumindest Valerie Haller
sehen Experten jetzt ein paar
Lichtblicke welche genau also einer der
Punkte den Ökonomen und
Wirtschaftsinstitute immer wieder nennen
ist der milde Herbst der spielt eine
große Rolle dadurch wird weniger
energieverbraucht und es wird
unwahrscheinlicher das Betriebe wegen
gasmangels zwangsweise heruntergefahren
werden müssen und auch für den Winter
sieht es recht gut aus der deutsche
Wetterdienste wartet er milde
Temperaturen hinzu kommt laut
Statistischen Bundesamt dass die
industrievolle Auftragsbücher hat und
damit ein komfortables Polster für
schwerere Zeiten hilfreich auch dass die
Lieferengpässe die die Wirtschaft lange
ausgebremst haben nachlassen langsam
zwar aber immerhin zudem rechnet das
gewerkschaftsnahe Institut im damit das
staatliche Hilfsprogramme wie
Kinderbonus und gaspreisbremse auf die
Wirtschaft stabilisierend wirken das
alles könnte den privaten Konsum stützen
und damit die Konjunktur insgesamt an
der Börse hat die Stimmung schon vor
Wochen gedreht spätestens als ich
gezeigt hat dass die Inflationen den USA
zurückgeht heute gab es zwar einen
Dämpfer aber in den vergangenen Wochen
legte der Dax ein beachtliches plus aufs
Parkett 17 Prozent seit Oktober dass die
kommenden Monate belastend werden daran
zweifelt niemand aber nach all den
düsteren Prognosen ein kleiner
Hoffnungsschimmer dass die Stimmung zur
Zeit vielleicht doch schlechter sein
könnte als die Lage vielen Dank Valerie
für diese Einordnungen
und jetzt die Lottozahlen von diesem
Mittwoch die lauten 1 9 11 30 35 37
Superzahl 8 alle Angaben wie immer ohne
Gewähr
Monate lang musste der Staat der NASA
Mondmission Artemis eins wegen
technischer Probleme und schlechter
Wetterbedingungen verschoben werden doch
heute morgen war es dann soweit und die
unbemannte Orion Kapsel konnte vom
Weltraumbahnhof
im US-Bundesstaat Florida abheben die
NASA will mit der Mission die Rückkehr
von Astronauten auf den Mond ab 2025
vorbereiten
und das war unsere Welt hier auf der
Erde im heute journal an diesem Mittwoch
von uns allen auch dem Team hinter den
Kameras danke dass Sie dabei waren und
auch der Hinweis auf unser heute journal
Update das gibt es heute gegen 0 Uhr mit
Christopher wermann in allen angenehmen
Abend tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend über Wochen ja fast über
Monate haben uns die Tiefs über dem
Atlantik mit sehr milden Temperaturen
versorgt das aber ändert sich jetzt und
das liegt an diesem Hoch über
Skandinavien so breitet sich bis zum
Wochenende die Kälte aus Nordosteuropa
bei uns aus heute Nacht sinken die
Temperaturen hier in Nordosten auf drei
bis ein Grad Milch bleibt die nach
dagegen im Westen bei 9 bis 7 Grad und
heute Nacht fällt noch Regen zwischen
Schleswig-Holstein und der Lausitz und
von Südwesten kommt neuer Regen heran
und der breitet sich morgen über Tag
weiter nach Nordosten aus den äußersten
Nordosten wird er wieder nicht erreichen
so wird es zwischen dem nördlichen
Brandenburg und der Ostseeküste Freund
ich bleiben das liegt am starken ja
stürmischen Wind aussieht als sich in
Richtung in Südwesten lockern die Wolken
auf und mit diesem Südwestwind und
Sonnenschein klettern dort die
Temperaturen bis 17 Grad nur vier Grad
sind es dagegen an der Ostsee und dann
breitet sich diese Kälte über ganz
Deutschland aus am Sonntag erwarten uns
nur noch Höchsttemperaturen zwischen 0
und 10 Grad bei 0 bis 3 Grad da kann es
auch durchaus mal schneiden naja am
Freitag liegt noch nicht viel Schnee
aber bis Sonntagabend könnte es hier und
da dann doch mal für eine kleine
schneege Überzuckerung der Landschaft
reichen gefährlich aber wird es wenn der
milde Regen über die Kälte am Boden
sieht dann droht nämlich Glatteis sonst
nur Schneeregen guten Abend